good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight this evening we've got
brand new numbers striking numbers that
have never been seen before and they may
reshape how you think about illegal
immigration so you've heard the same
line a million times it's repeated like
a mantra by the left during every debate
on the subject all immigrants are
hardworking and law-abiding they do jobs
you wouldn't consider doing and they do
them cheerfully they sacrifice for their
families in ways you probably don't in
fact and this is always the last point
it's always delivered with the
confidence satisfaction of someone
shutting down a debate with superior
data undocumented immigrants actually
commit fewer crimes on average than
native-born Americans not only are
immigrants more virtuous than you are
but they're safer to be around in other
words stop complaining they're your
superiors but wait are we sure that that
is true our people who are in this
country precisely because they were
willing to break our immigration laws
really less likely to break other kinds
of laws it doesn't make a lot of sense
yet until today strangely enough no one
could say for sure whether it was true
because reliable statistics didn't seem
to exist our government tracks pretty
much every trend in every phenomenon you
can think of from how many pounds of
pistachio nuts are recalled every year -
how many fifth graders are injured on
swing sets now do people die in bathtubs
this is a nation of record keepers were
overseen by an army of spreadsheet
wielding bureaucrats numbers control our
lives he said on this subject somehow
the government went for years without
honestly trying to track the volume of
crime committed by illegal immigrants in
this country maybe they were too
incompetent to do it more likely they
didn't want you to know the answer or to
think about it even in any case we now
for the first time have the actual
numbers in here they are according to
statistics from the US Sentencing
Commission non-citizens are actually far
more likely to commit serious crimes
that Americans are not a citizens
account for 22 percent more than a fifth
of all federal murder convictions 18
percent of fraud convictions 33 percent
of money-laundering convictions 29
drug trafficking convictions and 72% of
convictions for drug possession
meanwhile the non citizen percentage of
the American population about 7% so that
is a massively disproportionate amount
of crime not even close
no immigrants are not more law-abiding
and less dangerous than Americans that's
totally untrue indeed it's the opposite
of the truth non-citizens are more
likely to be arrested convicted and
imprisoned for serious crimes than
people who were born here much more
likely so why didn't we know this until
now why have so many people been lying
to us about this for so long that's a
question we plan to ask a whole bunch of
people well we'll start tonight with
Allen irani he is executive director of
the national immigration for many drug
joins us in the studio thanks doc for
coming on thanks for having it so this
is a conversation I've had I don't know
a dozen times in the past month on this
show where people say well actually
non-citizens are less likely to commit
crimes and they cite some Cato study or
something now we have definitive numbers
on this from you a Sentencing Commission
that shows that non-citizens are not
just more likely to commit crime serious
crimes like murder and fraud drug
trafficking but far more likely to
commit those crimes why are we just
learning this now well the bigger
question I think Tucker is how do we
make sure that we are keeping the nation
secure in a way that's using our
valuable law enforcement resources the
best way because I'll be the first to
tell you that we are a nation of laws
and we're in law and we're a nation that
should be keeping Americans safe
right so let's make sure that law
enforcement are in a position to do
their job and get those violent threats
those public safety threats off the
streets particularly if they're
immigrants and the way you do that is
that you make sure that the immigrant
community can trust local law
enforcement so that's why I'm concerned
about the direction of the
administration when it comes to
immigration enforcement because they're
actually undermining the ability of our
so enforcing I this is like this weird
alchemy where enforcing border laws
makes us less safe somehow but let me
ask you if 22 percent of all federal
murder convictions are of non-citizens
but only 7 percent of the population is
non citizen that suggests we're letting
in the wrong people it
suggests that we should be doing a much
better job in terms of a local law
enforcement and the way to do that is to
make sure that the immigrant community
is in a position to report crimes
because at the end of the day those
those individuals who are immigrants are
committing those crimes you know who the
like the most likely victim is the
immigrant well that's irrelevant saying
that let's just pause and what these
numbers kind of settle because these are
not in public until today twenty-two
percent of all federal murder
convictions non-citizens 33 percent of
money-laundering convictions
non-citizens 29 percent of drug
trafficking 72% of all convictions for
drug possession non-citizens
non-citizens are far more likely to
commit serious crimes than need of porn
citizens and foreign-born citizens for
that matter
why shouldn't this make us want to
radically curtail immigration into the
country it makes me radically want to
make sure I radical even want to make
sure that law enforcement are able to do
their job because again those those
crimes are being committed within the
immigrant community so no but I mean
those are some aren't well hold on we've
got these numbers today so we actually
don't really know where these crimes are
being committed or not anything about it
other than this like this is the first
no but if you actually date if you look
at the research the research shows that
the immigrant community is the victim of
is the disproportionate doesn't matter
why are we letting in people who are
many times more likely to commit murder
fraud drug trafficking than people were
born here why don't we think through who
we let in doesn't it suggest that to you
it suggests to me that our immigration
system is fundamentally broken and we
need to make sure that those individuals
are here who are undocumented are
registering for legal status passing a
criminal background check learning
English and coming out of that you've
got your pre-existing priorities that
you want I understand you do it for a
living
okay and I respect that but again for
the first time these are brand new
numbers we didn't know them when we woke
up this morning now we do the debate is
over non-citizens far more likely to
commit dangerous crimes than citizens
so with that in mind does that shock you
it shocks me that we haven't been
addressing the problem the correct way
why have we been saying the opposite
with such great authority all these
years well actually you know according
to Cato or some think-tank
I mean can we just pause and say you
know we were totally wrong about what
we've been saying the problem here is
that we want to get violent criminals
off the streets is that correct
we don't want them in here in the fifth
place we don't we do another why are we
making law enforcement deal with these
people why don't we stop it at the
border and then we don't have to put our
police and citizens at risk I think
that's a great idea the way you do that
is that you make sure that you have a
functioning legal immigration system and
a process for people to go through the
only people who are hiding for a lot
from law enforcement I thought don't we
bring in more than a million people
legally every year it's clearly out of
an entry in the world we're also a much
bigger country than almost any other
coordinate in our workforce and our
workforce is actually much more dynamic
and maybe okay but leaving the economics
of it aside I mean that's another show
another debate but I just I just want to
acknowledge that one of the core
operating assumptions that we have had
for years and I've been at the center of
this debate was wrong not just wrong but
totally wrong it was a lie does that
make you reassess what you thought a
little bit what I want to try to assess
is how do we actually solve the problem
I mean we can you know if you want us to
quibble about statistics you should
bring somebody from Cato okay but it's
not it's not quibbling that's might what
we've been climbing is the very opposite
of the truth I am one focused on solving
problems that problem is individuals who
are here who are violent criminals and
public safety threats I want them off
the streets Tucker the only way you can
do that is to make sure that the crimes
they commit are being reported by the
victims and if the victim is an
immigrant we need to make sure that okay
but why well clearly someone's reporting
these crimes we don't have a problem
with that because again the mud I mean
we have disproportionately big numbers
here my question is why do you think
non-citizens are committing crimes at a
far greater rate than Americans are I
think we got to make sure that
individuals who are coming to the
country have been properly vetted
they're going through the process they
need to and the folks who are heroes you
Dante haven't been properly and the
folks that are here who are undocumented
we need to require they pass a criminal
background check that is our biggest
problem right now because the individual
undocumented immigrant who is a violent
threat to our public safety they they're
the ones hiding why wouldn't we just
build a wall like the public kind of
wants that what's your argument against
that exactly if you actually want to
solve a problem
at the border you want to actually focus
where the problem is the majority of
drugs guns and money are smuggled to
ports of entry but these are not drugs
and gun somebody these are people those
enterprise those who are committing
crime those crimes they're coming in
through ports do you think a wall
wouldn't help at all because why I want
to I want to put money where the risk is
on the border where the majority we
didn't even know there was this risk and
tell about two hours ago so what I mean
we should pause and think about these
numbers because they are shocking you
will concede that Thank You Ellie this
year